suponemos que te encanta el yogurt
helado y te gusta tanto que todos los
días al salir de la escuela exactamente
a las 4 pm sales de la escuela y llegas
a la tienda de yogurt helado y quieres
tu helado y la verdad es que no te gusta
estar esperando a que sea tu turno
entonces un día decide realizar un
estudio quiere saber cuál es la
probabilidad de que algún día de escuela
exactamente a las 4 pm haya una fila
para que te dentro el lado de cierta
longitud y tu estudio consiste en ir 50
veces a la tienda de yogurt helado
exactamente a las 4 pm y hacer algunas
observaciones como el tamaño de la fila
d
aunque hoy voy a poner por aquí dos
columnas está aquí el tamaño de la fila
y por aquí vamos a poner otra columna
que sea la cantidad de veces observada
aunque número
número de observaciones
observa
ciones entonces digamos que fuiste unas
50 veces a la tienda de helado de yogurt
exactamente a las 4 y de esas 50 veces
observaste que no había ni una sola
persona en la fila 24 veces y observas
te que había una persona en la fila 18
veces observas de una fila de dos
personas ocho veces y en todas esas 50
veces que fuiste a la tienda de yoghurt
helado no te tocó nunca que hubiera una
fila de más de dos personas
entonces basándonos en lo que has
observado cuál es la probabilidad de que
un día llegue después de la escuela a
las 4 pm exactamente y no encuentres a
nadie en la fila o encuentres a una sola
persona en la fila o encuentre esas dos
personas en la fila aunque hay
basándonos en esta información que has
observado cuál es la probabilidad de que
llegues a la tienda de helado
y hay a esta cantidad de personas en la
fila y bueno en realidad lo único que
puedes hacer es estimar la verdadera
probabilidad neutra pero lo bueno es que
hiciste 50 observaciones y esas no son
tan poquitas aunque hay aquí tienes 18
más 8 son 26 y 26 los 24 son 50 que es
el número total de observaciones que
hiciste y lo que podemos hacer es
encontrar cuál es la frecuencia relativa
de tener cero personas en la fila aunque
o cuál es la frecuencia relativa de
tener una persona en la fila y también
tenemos que sacar cuál es la frecuencia
relativa de tener dos personas en la
fila y entonces vamos a usar esas
frecuencias relativas para estimar la
probabilidad teórica que hay de fondo
ok vamos a poner una nueva columna por
aquí con las estimaciones de la
probabilidad estimación
estimación de la probabilidad
probabilidad y otra vez una buena
estimación de la probabilidad es la
frecuencia relativa de estas
observaciones ok y la frecuencia
relativa de observar 0 personas en la
fila es 24 el número de veces que
observamos 0 personas en la fila entre
el número total de observaciones o sea
50 entonces 24 entre 50
eso es 48.48 que también podemos decir
que es el 48% y ahora cuál es la
frecuencia relativa de observar una
persona en la fila pues observamos eso
18 veces 18 veces de las 50 veces que
fuimos a la tienda así es que tiene una
frecuencia relativa de 0.36
o también podríamos decir que es de 36%
y finalmente la frecuencia relativa de
ver una fila de dos personas es 88 entre
50 osea 0.16 que es el 16% y esto no es
tal cual la probabilidad teórica
esto es una estimación de la
probabilidad porque hay lo que tenemos
50 observaciones del tamaño de la fila y
lo que hacemos es ver qué proporción de
esas 50 observaciones tienen una sola
persona en la fila 20 personas en la
fila o dos personas en la fila no
necesariamente va a suceder así siempre
pero es una buena estimación de la
probabilidad ok porque son 50
observaciones que es un número bastante
decente y con esto que hemos hecho esas
50 observaciones podemos decir que
estimamos que hay un 48% de probabilidad
de no ver a ni una
la persona en la fila cualquier día que
vayamos a la tienda de yogurt helado a
las 4 de la tarde y estimamos que hay un
36% de probabilidad de que haya una sola
persona en la fila y finalmente
estimamos que hay una probabilidad de
16% de que haya dos personas en la fila
o bueno también podemos decir que hay
una probabilidad de 0.16 0.36 y 0.48 ok
pero bueno el chiste es que también es
importante notar que esta es una buena
distribución de probabilidad aunque y
recordemos cómo son las probabilidades
todas las probabilidades son números
entre 0 y 1
cierto o sus correspondientes
porcentajes y eso si lo cumplen estas
probabilidades y además la suma de todas
las probabilidades tiene que ser igual a
1 si estos son todos los posibles
resultados y bueno tal vez en la vida
real pueden suceder cosas más extrañas
puede ser que en un día extraño que haya
un suceso muy importante lleguen
doscientas personas a la tienda pero eso
es algo que no estamos considerando
porque nuestras 50 observaciones no
encontramos nunca una fila de más de dos
personas
entonces en nuestra estimación de la
probabilidad nosotros creemos que eso no
es posible que los únicos resultados
posibles son estos tres de aquí entonces
la suma de todas estas probabilidades
tiene que ser igual a 1 a ver veamos qué
pasa punto 16.36 eso es punto 52.48 eso
sí es igual a 1 así es que la suma de
las probabilidades de todos los posibles
resultados
si es igual a 1 ahora ya que hiciste
todo esto podemos hacer algo muy
interesante que podríamos por ejemplo
pensar en bueno en los próximos 2 años
vas a visitar la tienda de yogur helado
aproximadamente 500 veces que digamos
que vas a visitar visitar
quinientas veces a veces la tienda de
yogur helado y aquí la pregunta es más
bien como cuántas de esas veces
esperarías encontrarte con una fila de
dos personas basándonos en lo que habías
observado ok para hacer una estimación
de cuántas veces vamos a encontrar una
fila de dos personas en esas 500 veces
que visitamos la tienda podemos decir
oye estimamos que la probabilidad de
encontrar una fila de dos personas es
0.16 y vamos a ir quinientas veces 500
veces a la tienda entonces más o menos
esta parte de las 500 veces que vamos a
ir a la tienda nos vamos a encontrar con
una fila de dos personas nunca ahora
también en lugar de poner 0.16 podríamos
poner 850 más partes
así es que de las 500 veces que vamos a
visitar la tienda de yogur helado
esperamos que más o menos 850
partes de estas 500 veces nos
encontremos con una fila de dos personas
entonces multiplicamos por aquí 500
entre 50 eso es simplemente 10 y 10 por
8 es 80 así es que podemos esperar que
más o menos 80 veces encontremos una
fila de dos personas
ahora hay que aclarar que con esto no
estamos diciendo que exactamente 80 de
las 500 veces vamos a encontrar una fila
de dos personas ok
fácilmente podría pasar que la
encontráramos 85 veces o incluso 65
veces ok todo eso es posible lo único
que estamos diciendo aquí es que es más
probable que encontremos un número
cercano a 80 y eso es algo muy
importante
ok aquí lo que estamos haciendo es
estimar la probabilidad y la verdad de
la distribución de probabilidad es súper
difícil encontrarla lo único que podemos
hacer real
desestimarla ahora ya que tenemos una
buena estimación y para encontrarla lo
que hicimos fue ir a la tienda 50 veces
a medir el tamaño de la fila siempre
exactamente a las 4 de la tarde pero ahí
lo que hicimos fue tomar 50 experimentos
50 observaciones y con esas 50
observaciones si podemos tener una buena
estimación de la probabilidad de fondo y
con esa estimación podemos tener una
buena idea de que esperar en el futuro
ahora incluso aunque tuviéramos
exactamente la probabilidad que está de
fondo de todas formas no podemos
asegurar que vamos a observar
exactamente esto ok por qué sigue siendo
un evento aleatorio